grab some milk and pump yourself full of
compound V the first trailer for The Boy
season 4 has launched and boys we're in
for an action pack season I've left a
link to the trailer in the description
and keep in mind there will be genv
spoilers ahead for those who haven't
watched it finally make sure to like And
subscribe I plan on covering the entire
season it's pretty interesting that the
first shot we get is of homelander in
his apartment an apartment which like
homelander is completely manufactured
while it may be adorned with pictures of
American Founders and patriotism we all
know homelander doesn't give a
about that the only person he cares for
is himself in fact his apartment was
furnished not by himself but by VA to
give him this image of being a patriotic
hero check out this shot of va Tower
which is being reconstructed after the
attack from soldier boy at the end of
season 3 in genv we saw how VA covered
up the attack stating that soldier boy
was radicalized by the Russians the last
time we saw him if you don't count his
brief Cameo and gen V he was being
locked away by Grace mallerie here we're
at an abandoned VA video a parody of
Blockbuster we can see a polarity cutout
here for a movie called Static heat 3
there's even a poster for big Crazy Love
2 starring termite which we saw Emma
peruse in genv and there she is folks
the head popper herself Victoria Newman
she's alongside presidential candidate
Robert Singer this appears to be some
sort of Victory party as the two of them
hold their hands up and confetti and
balloons fall from the ceiling remember
that if singer wins the presidency
Newman is next in line should something
happen to him and for those who've seen
genv Newman is in possession of the
virus that can kill soups which I've
theorized she may use to either kill
homelander or protect herself and her
daughter from him here we have huie and
starlight or maybe I should say her real
name Annie January as at the end of
season 3 she hung up her cape and
decided to to become one of the boys
they are curiously outside the 21st
Precinct maybe they just got done
putting someone away or filing a report
against homelander for a brief moment
you can notice a boom mic on the bottom
right suggesting that there's some sort
of press conference here perhaps the
Press is expecting some sort of response
from her as it seems Starlight has
become the central figure head in a
clash between left and right-wing
ideologies we'll see her light up her
hand and I'm also curious if we'll see
her fly at the end of season 3 we saw
she can levitate outside VA Tower we can
clearly see this distinction between the
left-wing faction of Starlight
supporters in yellow and homelander
supporters in red and blue it looks as
though someone is going to make a speech
on this stage I think I know who but
that'll be in a bit here's the Deep with
his octopus Timothy who's probably his
only friend right now after his
estranged wife wrote a TL book about him
called into deep I love this shot of
Butcher and mother's milk at a
conspiracy theory convention called
Truth conon and it looks like mother's
milk has switched to skim because dudes
lost some weight there's a poster that
says Secrets Revealed solder boy held
captive by the CIA which ironically is
actually true and to the right we can
barely see this sign about how Dakota
Bob AKA Robert Singer the presidential
candidate uses mind manipulation and
trance techniques to manipulate the
masses here's Frenchy in some sort of
Warehouse notice the blood on these
Jitter Bean crates Jitter Bean is the
boy versus version of Starbucks and one
can even be found on the gulan campus in
the background we can make out who
appears to be Kimiko likely the culprit
behind all this Bloodshed in front of a
New York County Courthouse Starlight and
homelander supporters square off this
has got to be the trial of homelander
who at the end of season 3 lasered to
death a Starlight supporter in broad
daylight gen V hinted that he'd be going
on trial for this and during the town
hall a question was raised whether or
not a human jur can impartially make a
decision on homelander guilt since he is
a soup in the background on the
Starlight side we'll see a big banner
that reads homelander deserves prison
time while on the right a sign that
reads Justice for homelander a huge
brawl breaks out as Starlight looks on
shocked and homelander seems to be
enjoying it here we get our first look
at a character known simply as sister
Sage there's not much we know about her
but like a sage she seems to be very
intellectual we'll see her surrounded by
books and her voice over to homelander
is all about how the people in a
democracy will eventually tear each
other apart and the people need someone
to swoop in and save them it's almost as
if Sister Sage is manipulating
homelander to make him feel like he's a
great leader like Caesar but remember
Caesar was also a dictator whose lust
for power eventually got him killed
here's homelander in front of what
appears to be a TV set we'll see him
hold hands with a boy in a suit likely
his son Ryan who he introduced to the
world at the end end of season 3 we'll
see the two of them at a rally which
appears to be the same one from this
wide shot in attendance is Sister sage
in uniform and a new soup called
firecracker who has her own show called
truthbomb she seems very proun with her
gun and blazing belt and ammo sash but
look who it is in the background here
black noir who was killed by homelander
in season 3 either this is someone
pretending to be black noir in order for
VA to cover up his death or VA has
Resurrected him we'll later see him
alongside the deep in a train in the
comics the legend shares that lamp
lighter was once resurrected using new
vot technology but the caveat is that he
turned into a shell of the man he once
was either way it'll be nice to have our
favorite cartoon hallucinating soup back
and here's our first look at Jeffrey
Dean Morgan's character Joe Kesler we
don't know much about him other than he
has ties to Billy butcher now am I crazy
here or is this Zoe Newman Victoria's
daughter in season 3 we saw Victor Toria
inject her with compound V but we never
saw if any powers manifested here it
looks like she has these Medusa like
tentacles come out of her mouth as she
fights Kimo she's also in a hotel room
wearing a dress so maybe she's on the
campaign trail with her mother I could
not figure out who's being chased out
this window here maybe it's Kimo
considering the same black clothing and
it appears to be a hotel hallway but if
you zoom in here this person is being
chased by someone who looks to be secret
service and here's Queen May or at least
someone dressed up as Queen mave at a
Christmas Pageant nothing says the birth
of Jesus like adding in some soups here
we see this guy duplicating himself it's
super creepy not exactly sure the extent
of his power but his shirt reads
Starlight is a and it's probably not
something pleasant he's likely a
homelander supporter check out this
wormlike creature on butcher's Temple
remember that he wasn't given much time
to live being diagnosed with brain
lesions a result of him overusing temp V
Ashley asks who wants their balls
crushed as a naked and tied up Cameron
Coleman everyone's favorite news anchor
lays on the floor homelander here
doesn't look too happy as he flies off
the roof of this building now this is
super weird we have a train in what
might be homelander room at VA Tower in
front of him are what appears to be a
bunch of momentos this jar of hair maybe
Stormfront maves or mateline stillwells
the marriage photo of Stormfront and
Frederick VA to the bottom a sword and
to the right a milk measuring bottle we
know homelander likes his milk outside
it looks like Ryan is going to be in
some deep trouble as he uses his power
to throw a dude across into a nearby
building notice all the people recording
around him so this is probably not going
to go over well Joe Kessler asks who
came up with the ridiculous name of the
boys and judging by this office and
Joe's suit he probably does some work
for the government now the final shot is
of homelander covered in blood with
chunks of Flesh on him as he smiles he
looks to be in some sort sort of
elevator or cell God knows what kind of
he's gotten himself into absent
from the trailer were any of the main
characters from gen V so I'm curious how
the new guardians of gulan will fit into
all this or how our gang from genv will
escape their captivity but now I turn it
over to you I want to hear your thoughts
and theories on what will happen in
season 4 thanks for watching please be
sure to like And subscribe and for more
bad takes you can follow me on Twitter
and Instagram at thinkstory YT until
next time remember daddy love you very
much